wir trauern mit den familien um die
opfer
dies bis heute und auch in diesen
stunden und in minuten in so großer zahl
auch unter der zivilbevölkerung
gibt
und wir bewundern den mut
und den willen dieses volkes um seine
freiheit zu kämpfen
hier sind zugleich beschämt und bedrückt
dass wir diesem land und diesem volk
nicht schon haben früher helfen können
und wohl größte bewunderung und unser
größter respekt gilt dem frei gewählten
staatspräsidenten der ukraine präsident
wolodimir zielinski
diesen diesen mutigen mann der aus einer
jüdischen familie stammt als
drogenabhängig und als nazi zu
diffamieren wie ist der russische
präsident in dieser woche getan hat
zeigt ein ausmaß an niedertracht und
menschenverachtung wie wir es in den
letzten jahrzehnten auf diesem kontinent
nicht erlebt habe
also das ganze ja sie haben es so
ausgedrückt mit diesem krieg geht eine
zeitepoche in europa zu ende eine zeit
von der wir erhofft und geglaubt haben
dass sie in frieden und in freiheit und
natürlich auch im wohlstand im ganzen
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
voranschreitet seit wenigen tagen sind
wir nun eines besseren belehrt
brutal und rücksichtslos
hat ein autoritäres system ein
angriffskrieg mitten in europa bekommen
ja mitten in europa denn dieser krieg
für den stadt zwischen den beiden
territorial größten ländern europas
russland sein europäisches land und die
ukraine ist ein europäisches land der
krieg findet statt weniger als zwei
flugstunden von diesem ort aus dem wir
uns heute morgen an einem sonntag
treffen der bundeskanzler ich möchte
ihnen im namen der unionsfraktion und
der sie tragenden parteien cdu und csu
danken für ihre regierungserklärung
sie wissen
[Musik]
dass wir sehr darum bemüht sind mit
ihnen und den sie tragenden
koalitionsfraktionen einen gemeinsamen
weg in dieser zeit einer großen
herausforderung zu gehen wir haben in
den letzten tagen mit ihren
fraktionen um gemeinsame antworten
gerungen und wir geben sie wieder in
einem entschließungsantrag den wir heute
gemeinsam mit der spd den grünen und der
fdp
einbringen aber lassen nämlich das ganz
deutlich sagen dieser antrag ist nur das
gemeinsame minimum das wir heute hier
feststellen können wir haben und wir
behalten hoffentlich auch in der zukunft
eine klare auffassung zu diesem krieg
und seinem einzigen verantwortlichen der
verantwortliche mann heißt wladimir
putin
[Applaus]
auch stiefel aus diesem lupenreinen
demokraten der er nie war ist nun
endgültig und für alle welt sichtbar ein
kriegsverbrecher geworden
aber so ein krieg
gefehlt nicht einer allein und er
entsteht auch nicht ohne ein politisches
umfeld
das verantwortliche system um ihn herum
ist ein geflecht von
geheimdienstoffizieren und erprobten
meistern der politischen propaganda wie
etwa sein außenminister lawrow auf ein
geflecht einer großen gruppe
hemmungsloser oligarchen die sich die
ressourcen dieses landes unter den nagel
gerissen haben und vor allem aus einem
repressiven staatsapparat der ohne jeden
anflug von rechtsstaatlichkeit beliebig
verhaftet vergiftet in lager steckt
familien zerstört und auch nicht davor
zurückschreckt mitten in den ländern
westeuropas
auftragsmorden zufolge steckt
und damit an dieser stelle und meine
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen überhaupt kein missverständnis
entsteht die verantwortlichkeit liegt
allein dort und allein bei diesen
handelnden akteuren aber zu diesem
netzwerk zählen seit vielen jahren auch
mehr oder weniger gutgläubige
interessenvertreter in aller welt auch
und gerade hier in deutschland die sich
einmal als putin versteher gerieren das
andere mal als freunde russlands die bis
hin zu windigen
stiftungskonstruktionen nichts
unversucht lassen nichts unversucht
lassen
mit diesem system
mit diesem system geschäfte zu machen
und das ganze dann auch noch zu
versuchen der öffentlichkeit als
gemeinnützig zu vermitteln sie als
nützliche idioten ganz im sinne der
linien denkmuster zu bezeichnen ist dann
wohl noch die freundlichste umschreibung
dieses treibens auch und gerade hier in
potsdam mit
die bedrohung der ukraine durch einen
angriffskrieg ist aber nicht die einzige
bedrohung die wir in diesen tagen sehen
parallel zu den panzer rollen seit
jahren wellen von propaganda durch
europa die in zeiten der digitalisierung
und der sozialen netzwerke eine hohe
effizienz und damit einen großen schaden
erzeugen ein schaden der auch unsere
gesellschaftliche ordnung vom innen
bedroht meine damit zu dieser propaganda
zu dieser propaganda zählt seit langem
die behauptung die nato sei der
eigentliche aggressor gegen das
friedliebende russland dies ist in der
tat großartige land müsse sich nun so
der allmächtige staatsapparat und sein
präsident gegen eine militärische
bedrohung zur wehr setzen dabei wissen
sie es alle besser herr putin auch sie
sind und waren von der nato nie bedroht
das wissen sie auch das wissen sie auch
im damen und herren wenn sie von dieser
stelle aus sehen wer jetzt klatscht und
wer jetzt nicht klappt dann weiß ich
welche reden wie im verlaufe des
heutigen vormittags hier noch zu hören
bekommen von ganz links und von ganz
rechts auf dieser seite
das wissen wir jetzt schon hier
anzuschauen die sie dann hier gleich
sprechen werden aber meine damen und
herren die einzige die einzige bedrohung
dies für putin und seine nomenklatura
gibt die einzige bedrohung und die nimmt
er zu recht sehr ernst ist die bedrohung
seiner macht durch das eigene volk die
bedrohung durch freiheit und demokratie
auch in seiner nachbarschaft da ist die
bedrohung für dieses system und deshalb
und deshalb unterdrücke party im eigenen
land jede opposition und deshalb macht
der gemeinsame sache mit alexander
lukaschenko der heute an diesem tag hier
während wir hier zusammen treten ein
sogenanntes referendum in belarus
abhalten lassen um die verfassung zu
ändern und ab dem morgigen tag in diesem
land auch atomwaffen stationieren zu
können meine damen und herren das ist
die neue realität in der wir in dieser
woche aufgewacht sind die
staatengemeinschaft des westens
die europäer die amerikaner viele andere
länder auf der welt reagieren auf diesen
bruch des völkerrechts und aller
verträge die wir mit russland bisher
gemacht haben mit konsequenz und härte
russland wird international isoliert das
land und seine repräsentanten werden
auch persönlich sanktioniert dazu
gehören damit dass hier kreist auch von
meiner seite richtigerweise swift das
internationale zahlungssystem mit dem
jetzt russland aus dem internationalen
zahlungsverkehr ausgeschlossen
der bundeskanzler
herr bundeskanzler herzlichen dank dass
sie das heute morgen hier gesagt haben
dass sie in den letzten tagen darüber
intensive gespräche und verhandlungen
geführt haben einschließlich auch der
frage die denn mit waffenlieferungen aus
mehreren europäischen ländern nach in
die ukraine jetzt umzugehen ist wichtig
ist das klare und unmissverständliche
signal vom heutigen tag genug ist genug
das spiel ist aus
lassen nämlich aber auch sehr deutlich
sagen gefragt sind jetzt nicht gute
reden am heutigen tag alle gefragt sind
und gute regierungserklärung ja liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen eine gute
regierungserklärung gefragt sind
stringenz und durchhaltevermögen in den
nächsten tagen und wochen denn dieses
durchhaltevermögen kann schon in wenigen
tagen auf harte proben gestellt werden
die sanktionen werden wirkung entfalten
nicht nur in russland sondern auch hier
bei uns
der krieg in der ukraine wird
konsequenzen fordern nicht nur in der
verteidigungspolitik sondern auch in
vielen anderen bereichen
und deshalb herr bundeskanzler bieten
wir ihnen heute an dieser stelle ihnen
und ihrer regierung umfassende konkrete
hilfe und unterstützung an wenn sie um
unterstützung und zustimmung für die
jetzt notwendigen umfassenden sanktionen
werben und sie tun es ja heute morgen
dann werden wir das unterstützen und
nicht im kleinen herummäkeln wenn sie
eine umfassende
wenn sie eine umfassende ertüchtigung
unserer streitkräfte wollen und wir
wollen sie ganz offensichtlich ab heute
mit ihnen dann werden wir auch gegen
widerstände diesen weg mit ihnen gehen
wenn sie es für notwendig erachten die
energiepolitik und die ihrer regierung
neu auszurichten wenn sie mit uns der
meinung sind dass wir jetzt endgültig
auf keine weiteren optionen der
energieerzeugung mehr verzichten dürfen
dann finden sie dabei unsere tatkräftige
unterstützung
und wenn sie
wenn sie es so wollen wie sie das heute
morgen hier vorschlagen dann können wir
auch darüber der bundeskanzler reden
aber ein sondervermögen ist nicht ein
vermögen sondern ein sondervermögen sind
zunächst einmal neue schulden und wie
wir diese neuen schulden aufnehmen und
wie wir sie dann möglicherweise in
unserer verfassung verankern das geht
nicht allein mit einer
regierungserklärung am sonntagmorgen zu
machen darüber müssen wir dann in ruhe
und im detail sprechen
und lassen nämlich auch dies ganz klar
sagen lassen sie mich hier dies ganz
klar sagen das machen wir dann in allen
teilen gemeinsam nicht in der
arbeitsteilung dass wir mit ihnen für
die unangenehmen dinge den kopf
hinhalten und sie in ihrer koalition
dann unverändert weiter alle wohltaten
zu lasten der jungen generation
verteilen herr bundeskanzler als das
machen wir
aber
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das sind ja alles die mehr
oder weniger nahe liegenden
entscheidungen die wir jetzt kurzfristig
treffen müssen die eigentliche
herausforderung ist doch eine ganz
andere und sie liegt viel tiefer in
wahrheit stehen wir spätestens mit
dieser woche vor einem scherbenhaufen
der deutschen und europäischen außen-
und sicherheitspolitik der letzten jahre
und jahrzehnte
einige der einige der vermeintlichen
gewissheiten
einige der vermeintlichen gewissheiten
der letzten jahre gehören nun endgültig
der vergangenheit an wir sind nicht mehr
nur von freunden umgeben auch wir werden
durch einen aggressiven start in unserer
direkten nachbarschaft
bedrohten einseitige abrüstung führt
nicht zu mehr sondern zu weniger
sicherheit
oder hat im haus sind
oder hat hier im haus irgend jemand
vergessen dass die ukraine 1994 alle
ihre atomwaffen abgegeben hat um und im
gegenzug dazu von russland umfassende
und dauerhafte garantien der
territorialen integrität erhalten hat
man damit hat dass irgendjemand von
ihnen hier vergessen
und lassen sie mich das so sagen
lichterketten friedensgebete
ostermärsche sind eine schöne sache auch
wir haben heute morgen mit einer reihe
von abgeordneten aus dem deutschen
bundestag
auch wir haben heute morgen
auch wir haben heute morgen mit einer
gruppe von abgeordneten aus dem
deutschen bundestag und einigen
fraktionen um den frieden in der welt
gebetet und um das ende dieses krieges
gebetet aber meine damen und herren mit
moral allein wird die welt um uns drum
herum nicht friedlich schon gar nicht
mit der angeblich besseren moral die
immer wieder auch in deutschland
vorgetragen wird
der ukraine der ukraine jedenfalls haben
gute worte nichts genutzt auch nicht die
vertrackte mitgliedschaft in der nato
meine damen und schließlich auch
deutschland muss endlich bereit sein in
dieser welt seine interessen zu
definieren um vor allem bereit seien vor
allem bereit sein diese interessen auch
durchzusetzen
dazu zählt nicht nur aber auch die
fähigkeit das eigene territorium und die
eigene bevölkerung wirksam gegen jedwede
form der gewalt und der nötigung zu
schützen und zu verteidigen
die bundeswehr ist also gefragt ist die
bundeswehr ist dazu soweit sie gefragt
ist heute am tag jedenfalls nicht in der
lage
das sind
das sind also wenn da reagiere ich nicht
aber hier reagiere ich schon wenn sie
das zu einem thema der parteipolitischen
auseinandersetzung machen
dass wir was wir waren damen und herren
wir
sind in diesem haus und ich war schon
ziemlich früh dabei wir sind in diesem
haus alle miteinander verantwortlich
dafür dass die bundeswehr in dem zustand
ist in dem sie heute ist wir haben uns
bemüht wir haben uns bemüht das zu
verbessern vieles ist an ihnen
gescheitert wenn wir heute einen neuen
weg nach vorn geht dann gehen wir ihn
gemeinsam aber nur dann wenn wir ihn
jetzt wirklich gemeinsam nach vorn geht
und nicht wenn sie hier parteipolitisch
zurückblicken
das sind
das sind alles
ja das sind alles annahmen
das sind alles annahmen und politische
einschätzungen die sie hier im hause
teilen mögen oder auch nicht aber die
eigentliche
führungsaufgabe kommt in diesem
historischen augenblick so oder so auf
sie zu herr bundeskanzler
lassen sie mich deswegen abschließend
lassen sie mich deswegen abschließen aus
einer großen deutschen tageszeitung
zitieren dies vor einigen tagen aus
meiner sicht sehr präzise auf den punkt
gebracht hat der autor schreibt am
wochenende einer sehr ernüchternden
analyse wie folgt die eigentliche
rechnung aber wird in deutschland selbst
fällig wo diesen krisen dichte auf eine
weitgehend unvorbereitete bevölkerung
trifft der schlicht das handwerkszeug
fehlt um mit erpressung nötigung
militärischer bedrohung auf das
politische system umzugehen
unsicherheit so schreibt er weiter
entsteht in der regel durch einen
aggressor aber gefährlich wird sie erst
durch schwäche ende des zitats das
notwendige handwerkszeug herr
bundeskanzler
diese schwäche in unserem land zu
beseitigen
dieses notwendige handwerkszeug ist seit
dieser woche die historische aufgabe
ihrer kanzlerschaft herzlichen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
das hatte der oppositionsführer öffnet
nicht märz gerade im bundestag seiner
antwort auf die regierungserklärung von
olaf scholz eine sehr kämpferische rede
klaus eine sehr klare rede claus strunz
bild live bei uns im studio ja den ton
getroffen schwierig oppositionsführer
aber doch in einer großen einheit mit
den regierungsparteien
sehr geschickt gemacht wir sind
natürlich dabei bei dieser nationalen
kraftanstrengung aber wir lassen uns
auch nicht veräppeln wenn es dann darum
geht wer hinterher sozusagen die
politischen folgen zu tragen hat das hat
er gut gemacht er friedlich merkt sich
muss ohnehin jetzt nach den zwei großen
rednern sagen wir haben in den letzten
monaten und jahren darum gekämpft dieses
land neuen leuten anzuvertrauen in einer
neuen regierung und einer neuen
oppositions konstellation dieser morgen
gibt mir das gefühl es ist in richtigen
hin